miss you missed anything about pakistan
about where you grew up yeah i mean i
mean i miss a lot of things i have to
say that yeah we're not the most
laid-back people
but i mean you know some i'll tell you
this this this is this happened to me
this is one of the worst days of my life
and this happened in pakistan this is
when i was about 11 or so uh-huh and you
have i'll you have to know two things
before i tell you one
um i didn't i didn't start wearing
underwear
until i was too old
like okay this is the story
oh
i didn't know there was a age limit on
underwear wearing i feel like eleven's
too old to not be wearing underwear well
see what i'm saying yes you didn't start
wearing underwear until later on until
this
this is the story of why i started
wearing underwear
gather around everyone
let's get the campfire going i'm a
little a big prop book yeah
so what happened okay this story takes
place during what i call
the summer of masturbation
they're
they're not related they're not
connected in the way you think okay this
is the summer where i discovered
masturbation yeah and i was really just
pouring a lot of my time into that yeah
that was sort of like my project i'm
same way right off the bat i was a fan
yeah yeah
oh yeah totally it's like when i first
saw basketball i was like oh i'm gonna
like this forever yeah
that's how i was with masturbation right
and what happened was i had a cousin my
age he came over to my house and he
pulled me aside and he was like hey i
heard
i heard that if you hold your penis and
you go up and down something happens
right and i was like that sounds right
that feels right i was like you go in
the bathroom and you try it and then you
report back
he's in there for three minutes he comes
out and his face is red which is very
hard for my people to get a red fish
his face is red i asked him how it was
and his lips moved but no sound came out
and then i swear he picked up a bb gun
and shot a crow
and i was his face was red
he didn't speak he picked up a bb gun
and he shot a crowd shot a crow
and i was like i'm doing this right now
tonight we become men you know
so i go in
i get started
and i haven't you know it takes me 30
seconds like my body's been waiting like
this is what we wanted for so long right
at the point of impact i i black out
you blacked out i black out you black
out i black out and i wake up and i'm
laying on the floor of my bathroom yeah
and remember saying out loud to myself
oh this is going to be a problem
and it really was i was really like
going at it a lot you know
so i was like scheduling things around
it
wait did you faint every time no just
the first time oh okay all right i
didn't faint every time okay right
there's more details that i don't want
to get in sure of course yeah we don't
want to go down any untoward ropes right
that's a web extra
so um
so i'm doing this a lot i'm getting
embarrassed um i'm doing this a lot and
uh so this is we have a theme park in
karachi called fun land that's the name
of it it's called fun land which sounds
like a real first draft name
fun land we'll get to the real we'll
come up with something better but yeah
for now it's right around the corner
from work building and food room
so my cousins are gonna come over and
we're all gonna go to fun land now uh i
10 minutes i only have 10 minutes and
this would have been the third one of
the day but i'm like i could do it so 10
minutes third one of the day so i go in
and based on how much time i had and how
many times i've done it i think of
different situations
so this is you know i have to go for
nuclear option which is possessed
sigourney weaver and ghostbusters
that's the hottest thing i can think of
yeah
the possessed sigourney weaver not yes i
remember when she's cause it's like a
threesome with just one other person
yeah yeah yeah yeah cause you know the
gatekeepers in there too okay right
right
[Laughter]
so
imagine that little kid telling you this
story
so um my uh i get started and i've
missed time mistimed it my cousins show
up my mom's yelling at me we gotta go we
gotta go
very stressful i get it done i get the
job done
i pull up my pants if you remember
i didn't wear underwear
i
zip
through my penis
i zipped through my penis
i didn't you didn't chop it off no that
would have been the first thing i would
have mentioned i wouldn't i would have
been like a story of how i lost my dick
right right that would have been right
different title yeah it would have been
a different title yeah right in the
intro we would have said star of silicon
valley [ __ ]
i'd be like i introduce everyone like
hey two things about me i'm from
pakistan and i have half a day yeah yeah
yeah
i know you have questions yeah
life in pakistan wasn't easy yeah
so you were saying you took a chunk off
the side you took the piece off the side
took a piece off the side just the
littlest piece
but it felt giant
and it wasn't even stuck in there i was
like ty it's done party's over
and it's bleeding and it's bleeding a
lot and i'm a kid i don't want it to get
infected so i get my dad's aftershave oh
my god
oh my god
down there
and it felt like a fire had teeth
it's like the kind of pain where you're
flashing like football highlights and
pictures of all your dead relatives
and the orcs marching out of mordor yeah
which those movies hadn't even come out
right it hurt so much i had a prophecy
[Laughter]
and the next day
i went and i bought underwear the post
script to that story is things are great
down there now things happen okay thank
you you got everything all right high
five everything's great down there
everything's great down there
right you're all fine yeah but there is
a scar that needs to
be addressed
it needs to and so now i'm married so
it's fine but for years when i'd gotten
charmed someone to the point where they
might see it i kind of had to prep them
i had to be like hey when you get down
there
there's going to be something weird it's
not that weird
it's kind of weird
in pakistan we have a theme park called
fun
what a nice story to tell